und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt der chef
der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz eine
entscheidende stimme also heute
nachmittag
cdu-ministerpräsident hendrik wüst aus
nordrhein-westfalen guten morgen herr
wüst
und morgen herr wüst es sind
einschneidende maßnahmen kontakt
beschränkungen ab dem 28 zwölfter
angekündigt wie lange werden diese
einschränkungen dauern
die experten beschreiben die fünfte
welle die jetzt auf uns zukommt als sehr
sehr gefährlich wir müssen jetzt
entscheidungen treffen damit wir auch
unsere kritische infrastruktur
beispielsweise aufrechterhalten und
niemand kann heute sagen wann das vorbei
sein wird oder zu welchen maßnahmen wir
noch gezogen sein werden was bedeutet
welche maßnahmen noch sie haben auch in
interviews bereits angekündigt dass es
zu weiteren maßnahmen kommen könnte
droht also doch wieder ein richtiger
lockdown
ich warne dringend davor jetzt dinge
auszuschließen das ist in der pandemie
zu oft passiert das hat auch
glaubwürdigkeit gekostet und wir sollten
heute gar nichts ausschließen wir
sollten uns jetzt vorbereiten wir
sollten einen plan entwickeln für die
kommenden wochen damit wir gut durch
diese zeit kommen also schließen sie den
locker und auch nicht aus was könnte das
bedeuten wieder geschlossene schulen
wieder geschlossene gastronomie
das ist rechtlich aktuell gar nicht
möglich die neue mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag die ampel hat das alles
ausgeschlossen man hat sich dieser
mittel gegeben ob das ausreichend ist
was wir heute haben werden wir
diskutieren müssen die experten
jedenfalls haben mit blick auf omikron
deutlich mahnend uns dazu getrieben noch
mal zusammen zu kommen das war mir
wichtig aber darauf gedrungen dass sie
auch vor weihnachten jetzt noch einmal
zusammenkommen und entscheidungen
treffen
und den rest müssen sie die ampel fragen
ob man da bereit ist weitere
möglichkeiten zu schaffen um die
menschen zu schützen wenn es nötig ist
aber sie wären dazu bereit zu einem
weiteren lockdown auch für gastro
schulen usw
oberste priorität muss ja sein die
gesundheit leib und leben der menschen
zu schützen deswegen kommen wir jetzt
zusammen um uns vorzubereiten um einen
plan zu entwickeln
und wenn all das noch nicht reichen
sollte muss man wieder zusammenkommen
sie haben eine katastrophen szenario
beschrieben den zusammenbruch der
kritischen infrastruktur was genau würde
das bedeuten herr wüst
genau das zu verhindern ist einer der
wesentlichen punkte heute neben dem
booster neben den kontrakt beschränkung
das wir uns vorbereiten auf die fünfte
welle auch darauf dass viele menschen
erkrankt sind bei leichten verläufen
auch dann müssen sie zu hause bleiben
angehörige müssen den quarantäne und
wenn gleichzeitig viele menschen
ausfallen im job beispielsweise in der
strom- und wasserversorgung müssen wir
uns ja heute darauf vorbereiten deswegen
ganz wichtig heute zusammen zu kommen
angesichts dieser neuen bedrohungslage
jetzt nicht fast schon ein bisschen zu
spät damit
sie haben wir eine situation dass die
vierte welle langsam abebbt wir haben
niedrige zahlen wir haben exzellente
fortschritte beim fußball in nordrhein
westfalen werden anderthalb bis zwei
millionen menschen jede woche geimpft
jetzt geht es um vorbereitung und weil
wir wissen von den experten dass omikron
sehr sehr schnell ist ist es gut und
richtig dass wir bevor diese welle
richtig losgeht schon konsequent handeln
und uns vorbereiten aber auch einen plan
dafür entwickeln was in den nächsten
wochen vor uns kommen vor uns steht ein
punkt der beschlussvorlage heißt dass
herr wüst überregionale sport kultur und
großveranstaltungen finden spätestens ab
28 dezember ohne publikum statt was
heißt das ist also das neujahrskonzert
beispielsweise nicht mehr möglich mit
publikum was ist mit gottesdiensten
das heißt dass wir an allen stellen im
kleinen wie im großen sehr sehr
vorsichtig sein müssen und es ist jetzt
nicht die zeit für große veranstaltung
wo viele tausend menschen zusammenkommen
gemeinsam anreisen um reisen vielleicht
vorher oder nachher noch ins restaurant
in die kneipe gehen das ist jetzt
einfach nicht die richtige zeit mit
einem so gefährlichen virus mit dieser
gefährlichen mutation um die kunden das
heißt ganz konkret also haben auch
nochmal gastronomie die kneipe
angesprochen die diskotheken sollen ja
geschlossen werden die kneipen
geschlossen werden es geht also alles
schon sportveranstaltungen abgesagt ohne
zuschauer wie lange kann man das halten
wann kommt man wieder zusammen das ist
hier in der beschlussvorlage noch offen
es ist wohl ein termin im januar
angedacht und jeder von uns fragt sich
was kommt denn dann
in den meisten ländern sind ja die disco
schon seit wochen geschlossen bei uns in
nordrhein westfalen auch die restaurants
sind noch geöffnet man könnte sie gar
nicht schließen weil die rechtsgrundlage
von der ampel abgeschafft worden ist
jetzt geht es darum gut über den
jahreswechsel zu kommen gut vorbereitet
zu sein auf die fünfte welle aber wir
brauchen darüber hinaus einen plan für
die nächsten wochen und darüber muss man
dann spätestens im januar wieder
zusammen kommen er wird den usa ist
durch omnicom die zahl der infektionen
innerhalb von nur einer woche von 12
prozent auf 72 prozent 73 prozent
sprunghaft angestiegen man könnte auch
anders herum argumentieren und sagen die
maßnahmen die sie jetzt im blick haben
also einfach eine kontakt beschränkung
zunächst sie sind einfach viel viel zu
lasch
ja gerade weil wir das sehen auch die
entwicklung der eine mag in den
niederlanden weil sie die warnung des
rki auch ernst nehmen dass auch menschen
die zweimal geimpft sind jetzt ein hohes
risiko haben krank zu werden kommen wir
ja gerade jetzt vor weihnachten noch mal
zusammen aufsetzend auf die
einschränkungen auf die maßnahmen auf
den schutz der letzten wochen noch mal
darauf zusätzliche kontakt
beschränkungen der klaren appell auch an
weihnachten besonders vorsichtig zu sein
sie haben selber eben die maßnahmen den
katalog beschrieben auch absage von
großveranstaltungen
all das soll ja genau diese schnelle
ausbreitung von unicom bremsen vielen
dank herr wüst